minha primeira experiência como
professora foi corrigindo um monte de
prova uma pilha assim que uma criança
encontrou naquelas pilhas de poleto de
propaganda sabe que eu encontrei em
algum canto e algum comércio da cidade
eu dava vários certos porque aqueles
alunos eram ótimos e eu como professora
me sentir muito orgulhosa daqueles
alunos que eu tinha uma outra
experiência foi naquelas lousas
fictícias né que a criança fantasiava
enquanto brincava de escolinha e essa
experiência de professora foi
acontecendo temos 13 14 anos quando
efetivamente eu passei a ter a companhia
do outro
quando eu comecei a ajudá lo os meus
amigos de escola orientada uma ajuda uma
dica né as aulas de inglês
a partir desse momento eu entendi o
quanto é importante a presença de uma
outra pessoa
na educação o quanto era mágico a gente
entender que que maravilhoso que era
você conseguir ajudar uma pessoa a
conseguir caminhar com as próprias
pernas ajudar uma pessoa a conseguir a
pensar com as próprias idéias e aí a
partir desse dia eu entendi o que é que
eu faria para o resto da minha vida
a educação como a gente conhece e sabe
ela é vista de diversos ângulos diversos
olhares muitas pessoas adoram opinar e
dizer que tem razão sobre sobre ela
muitas vezes por motivos econômicos por
motivos políticos né e dentro dessa
discussão toda
muitas vezes o que acaba acontecendo é
essa discussão fazer com que a educação
como foco seja desconectada da pessoa
que é o centro eo motivo pelo qual ele
existe que é o aluno a gente sabe que
conhecer saber das coisas é muito legal
mas eu acho que se a gente perguntar a
alguns alunos se eles gostariam de
nascer sabendo eu acho que muitas vezes
vão dizer que sim
se você não se assim se você perguntar
para o aluno bom você não gostaria de
nascer sabendo ele vai dizer sim então a
gente se pergunta se essa é a resposta
onde será que está o problema será que o
problema está no aprender
se o problema está no aprender no
processo de aprender o que está errado a
gente pode pensar que o processo de
aprender tem a ver com a preparação do
professor
o desinteresse do aluno ou a sala de
aula que não está devidamente preparada
pra ele
bom a gente ter ouvido falar muitas
vezes e por vários meios de comunicação
dos nativos digitais de prensky mesmo
então por conta disto do mundo disse
olha a sala de aula sem tecnologia os
alunos é é celular em sala de aula os
professores têm que trazer isso em
trazer aquilo tem que fazer aquilo outro
pois bem só que se vocês parem pra pra
pensar colocando tudo isso em cima do
papel do professor
eu volto um faz uma pausa nisso e faz
uma pergunta pra vocês
alguém aqui tem filho eu vou fazer uma
pergunta pra vocês alguma vez vocês
enquanto pais já se pegaram falando com
os seus filhos
exatamente da mesma maneira que seus
pais falaram com vocês e vocês só
perceberam isso
no momento em que aconteceu a nossa
parece meu pai falando comigo aparece a
mãe falando comigo né
e é curioso isso que acontece a gente
não sabia que a gente tinha esta memória
mas ela surgiu
mas eu vou dizer uma coisa pra vocês
os professores é a mesma coisa muitas
vezes os professores em sala de aula
eles vão reproduzir um determinado
comportamento que eles também não
conheciam e que só vão surgir na hora
que acontecer eu tenho certeza que os
professores deles não usavam nenhum tipo
de tecnologia digital
na época que esses professores eram
alunos
então o que eu quero dizer com isso que
esses professores que a gente hoje cobra
que usem que façam eles não aprenderam
desta forma então o que a gente precisa
fazer nesse sentido agentes ajudar a
gente precisa ensinar a gente precisa
desenvolver então como isso é possível
primeiramente é importante fazer com que
todos nós e principalmente o professor
nesse contexto
acredite que é possível porque sem a
crença de que de que o professor
consegue lidar com este desafio ele nada
vai fazer
a crença é uma coisa muito importante e
ela permeia ela faz o papel de mediadora
das nossas decisões das nossas vidas
sim o neo se a gente acredita que a
gente tem condição de fazer determinada
coisa a gente vai lá e faz
a gente acredita por outro lado que não
consegue a gente muitas vezes nem tenta
então se existem vários tipos de crenças
e uma das crianças que eu gostaria de
falar a respeito bem rapidinho é uma
criança chamada auto eficácia alta
eficácia é a crença que você tem na sua
capacidade do executivo organizar e
executar alguns cursos de ação que são
necessários para você dar conjunta
determinada tarefa
a boa notícia é que a gente consegue
ajudar uma pessoa a desenvolver o seu
senso de auto eficácia e isso não é só
pra dar a aula não é só usar
tecnologia isso pra qualquer coisa pra
falar em público
acho que a determinado esporte pra
aprender a lidar com algum tipo de
dificuldade
então muitas vezes um professor ele pode
ser um excelente professor e ter uma
alta altitude cássia pra dar aula mas se
ele não acredita que ele consegue usar
uma tecnologia para poder promover um
resultado de aprendizagem com o uso da
técnica aquela tecnologia ele
simplesmente não vai usar tão rapidinho
como é que eu posso fazer para ajudar
esse professor tem quatro meios
o primeiro deles é fazer com que esse
professor tenha uma experiência pessoal
de uso de tecnologias sala de aula eu
ajudo esse professor a a preparar uma
aula e aplicar uma aula usando ou um
aplicativo ou uma tarefa muito pequena
na qual ele vai fazer com que o aluno
use e depois essas tarefas vão sendo
gradativamente maiores de forma que o
professor participe cada vez menos que o
aluno participe cada vez mais a aula
uma outra forma é fazer com que o
professor
observe um amigo dele um colega fazendo
a mesma coisa de forma que ele perceba
que as dificuldades que ele tem o colega
também tem e assim ele aprende com
semelhante a uma outra forma é fazer com
que ele receba o tempo todo o feedback
positivo seja dos seus pares seja da
pessoa que está desenvolvendo um
orientador o treinador o diretor gestor
e dos próprios alunos ea última forma é
fazer com que ele aprenda a identificar
e controlar o que a gente chama de
estados fisiológicos sabe suor na mão o
friozinho na barriga que são sinais que
o corpo dá pra gente que a nossa auto
eficácia está abalada ou controlada bom
de um lado a gente tem o que fazer com o
professor e do outro lado do outro lado
queria experiência é que são as quatro
fontes
é do outro lado tem isso
alguém sabe o que é isso
pequenina que cê é a pergunta que não
quer calar
a pergunta que não quer calar é como
fazer para o aluno querer aprender todo
o professor faz essa pergunta é né esse
é o nosso grande drama
só que antes de responder essa pergunta
tem que devolver a pergunta o professor
que é a pequena que será a as primeiras
cinco letras você já sabe
7 a pergunta que não quer calar anterior
a gente tem que perguntar para o
professor o seguinte por que é que o
aluno tem que aprender
aquele determinado conteúdo
se a resposta for hora porque está no
currículo porque tá no livro porque vai
cair na prova
se estas forem as respostas nós temos um
problema
se estas forem as respostas a gente
simplesmente está desconectando os
nossos alunos da escola
a gente tá desconectando os nossos
alunos da vontade de aprender
então só pra ilustrar eu vou trazer
alguns exemplos da área que eu atuo que
é o ensino de língua estrangeira
se eu que se eu quiser com os meus
alunos aprendam números qual a atividade
possível que a gente pode fazer eu vou
pedir para que esses alunos mantêm os
seus grupos de rock zap no celular
então o país poderia montar o grupo d
ossa porque eles preciso fazer descobrir
o número do outro para poder descobrir o
número do outro ele precisa perguntar e
com isso pratica números pra que eles
possam colocar o seu perfil
edin que é uma rede social basicamente
profissional eles precisam saber falar
minimamente da própria profissão
então eles vão poder tem que aprender a
falar a respeito da própria profissão
pra poder postar na internet eles podem
falar a respeito da própria cidade tem
um site nettheim esses bip dia da vida
de enxame que tcheco eles poderem falar
a respeito da própria cidade postar de
verdade para que outros vejam tem que
pesquisar que tem na minha cidade que
tem uma gestão que tem um restaurante
você comparações com mais legal eles
fazem a pesquisa faz comparações e
postam aqui eu só queria fazer uma pausa
os professores muitas vezes quando
pensava que legal usar a internet na
sala de aula
a primeira coisa que ocorre é usar a
internet para buscar informação
só que a informação já existe né então a
gente tem sempre que se lembrar o
seguinte o conteúdo já existe conteúdo é
pronto ele é finito ele já está lá a
gente não tem que trabalhar enquanto
educador a favor do conteúdo alguém já
fez isso que nós precisamos fazer é
trabalhar a favor do aluno e se está em
desenvolvimento e se está informação
nós todos estamos na verdade então a
internet tem que ser usada para criar e
compartilhar conteúdo não só buscar né
então deixou fechar o parêntese
continuar então a fazendo uso desse
jeito
o aluno passa a entender que ele tem
condições de participar da aula de um
jeito muito mais significativo né
então a gente vê exemplos disso
acontecendo em muitas disciplinas e
trouxe um pedacinho da minha porque eu
não vou usar né entrar em outras mas por
exemplo a gente vê tá chegando no brasil
eu acho que vocês já ouviram falar
uma uma pedagogia chamada maker né então
que a pedagogia meio faz os alunos eles
têm que construir coisas em sala de aula
então isso mostra
a evolução ea diferença que a sala de
aula tendo hoje
antigamente a sala de aula era um
silêncio total
a sala de aula era um espaço aonde o
aluno e buscar conhecimento porque
porque efetivamente todo o conhecimento
do mundo ele era trazido para dentro da
sala de aula então a sala de aula era um
silêncio todos saber vinha do professor
o aluno de ficar quietinho que aquele
tempo tinha que ser otimizado e à
otimização do tempo era via silêncio
hoje a sala de aula é um espaço do fazer
ela é um espaço do culto experimentar é
um espaço do ter que errar então não
podemos mais ter sala de aula com o
silêncio a sala de aula não pode em
hipótese alguma ser o intervalo do mundo
ela tem que ser o próprio mundo e
evolução em teste em experimentação e o
papel da tecnologia é justamente servir
de meio para que o aluno faça esses
testes faça essa experimentação e isso
não é fácil para o professor
por isso que a gente precisa enquanto
educador enquanto o desenvolvedor de
professor ajudá lo a ajudar aos pais
principalmente a entender esse novo
papel do professor porque não é fácil
não é fácil fazer com que a essa
experimentação ocorra porque a gente não
sabe onde vai dar é fácil quando você
tem um conteúdo o aluno tem que decorar
e responder
antigamente a gente ensinava aluno a
responder
hoje a gente tem que ensinar o aluno a
fazer perguntas
essa é verdadeiro intuito é ensinar a
fazer perguntas e perguntas cada vez
mais inteligentes perguntas cada vez
mais sem resposta e os pais muitas vezes
não entendem isso e quanto mais a gente
conseguir ensinar o aluno a fazer
perguntas que não têm respostas mais
estamos conectando os alunos da escola
então a pra poder só sintetizar o que eu
gostaria de dividir com vocês a existem
diversas iniciativas a iniciativa maker
é uma que eu trouxe mas essas
metodologias ativas é que inclusive as
próprias universidades
agora estão começando a trabalhar com
esse tipo de metodologia é baseada em
problemas em estudos de caso em
pesquisas em várias universidades do
próprio brasil já estão começando a
trabalhar com com com esse tipo de
experimentação ea aquele conteúdo que a
gente só via no livro passou a ser
dividido parte está no livro artista
digital
então a gente pode fazer com que o aluno
veja um pouco no livro um pouco na parte
digital seja sozinho seja em estações
que ele roda ao longo da sala de aula
então veja isso demanda do professor uma
grande alta eficácia para lidar com a
situação como essa então ele ele roda em
estações o roda individualmente ou
outras vezes ele tem que se preparar em
casa através de vídeos através de
pesquisas e no dia seguinte ou na aula
seguinte ele vem pra sala de aula pra
poder debater sobre aquilo que ele viu
anteriormente
então a gente inverte é o que tem sido
chamado de sala de aula invertida
então a esse tipo de de mudança a
tecnologia faz com que o ambiente
inteiro mude não é só porque a
tecnologia está inserida que eu vou que
que a pedagogia continua a mesma muda
tudo as relações mudam a proposta muda a
maneira como tudo é visto é alterado
outro dia vi na televisão uma um
comercial de uma cidade que estava
orgulhosamente é investindo a investimos
em tecnologia
a educação ea e colocou a foto de uma
professora em uma loja digital ea a a
professora estava usando um texto e ela
tava grifando um texto da mesma maneira
como ela fazia com giz
então isso prova o que investiu em
tecnologia mas não investiu na formação
do professor
então não é o suficiente não é só um
controle que vai mudar é é a formação
que vai fazer a diferença
então para encerrar que o tempo já
estourou é só queria dizer o seguinte
que todos nós sabemos o que tem que ser
feita é preciso investir nas pessoas
para que a conexão só se dá quando a
gente faz a pra que o aluno seja
conectado à escola efetivamente a gente
tem que esquecer tudo isso em relação a
conteúdo e pensar na verdadeira
protagonista que é o aluno é uma vez que
que isso acontece quanto mais o
professor sair de cena mas mas ele vai
se conectar
é isso obrigado
[Aplausos]